PROFESSOR: So we
have this integral.
And with-- let me
go here, actually.
With the counter gamma equal
to C1, this counter over here,
and the constant c equal to 1.
So C1 and the
constant c equal to 1.
This psi that we have
defined, psi of u,
is in fact the
airy function of u.
A i of u.
I is not--
I think I tend to
make that mistake.
I doesn't go like a subscript.
It's A i like the first
two letters of the name.
So that's the function A i of u.
And now you could ask, well,
what is the other solution?
Now, in fact, this
diagram suggests to you
that there's other
solutions because you
could take other counters
and make other solutions.
In fact, yes, there
are other ways.
For example, if
you did a counter--
do I have a color?
Other color?
Yes.
If you did a counter like
this, yellow and yellow,
this is not the same solution.
It is a solution because
of the general argument
and because the endpoints
are in these regions
where things vanish at infinity.
So the yellow thing
is another solution
of the differential equation.
So the other airy function
is defined, actually,
with this other counter.
It's defined by taking the
yellow counter like this.
This is going to be called C2.
A counter like that.
It just comes parallel to
this one and then goes down.
And, actually, in order to
have a nicely defined function,
one chooses for the function
B i of u the following.
Minus i times the integral
over the counter C1
of the same integrant.
So I will not copy it.
Always the same integrant.
Plus 2 i terms the integral
over the counter C2
of the same thing.
So the B i function
is a little unusual
in that it has kind of a
little bit of the A i function
because you also
integrate over C1.
But you integrate
as well over C2.
That guarantees that-- actually,
this second airy function
behaves similar to
A i for negative u,
and while A i goes
to 0 for positive u,
this one will diverge.
There are expressions
for this function.
I'll give you an integral.
2 integrals that are famous
are A i of u equals 1 over pi.
Integral from 0 to infinity.
d k cosine.
k cubed over 3 plus k u.
And for B i of u.
1 over pi-- this
is a little longer.
Integral from 0 to
infinity as well.
d k.
And you have an exponential of
minus k cubed over 3 plus k u,
plus the sine of k
cubed over 3, plus k u.
And that's it.
It's kind of funny.
One is the cosine
and one is the sine.
And it has this extra
different factors.
So these are your two functions.
And of the relevance
to our w k b
problem is that they're
necessary to connect
the solutions, as we will see.
But we need a little more
about these functions.
We need to know there
are asymptotic behaviors.
Now there are functions, like
the exponential function, that
has a Taylor series, e to the z.
1 plus z plus z squared over 2.
And it's valid,
whatever these angles--
the argument of z is.
That's always the same
asymptotic expansion,
or the same Taylor series.
For this functions,
like the airy function,
for some arguments of
u, there's one form
to the asymptotic expansion.
And for some other arguments,
there's another form.
That's sometimes called
the Stokes phenomenon.
And for example, the
expansion for positive u
is going to be a decaying
exponential here.
But for negative u, it
will be oscillatory.
So it's not like
a simple function,
like the exponential function
has a nice, simple expansion
everywhere.
It just varies.
So one needs to calculate
this asymptotic expansions,
and I'll make a small
comment about it
of how you go about it.
The nice thing
about these formulas
is that they allow you to
understand things intuitively
and derive things yourself.
Here you see the
two airy functions.
They make sense.
The other thing that
is possible to do
with this counter
representations
is to find the asymptotic
expansions of these functions.
And they don't require
major mathematical work.
It's kind of nice.
So let's think a little
about one example.
If you have the airy
function A i of u
that is of the form
integral 1 over--
well, it begins v k over 2 pi.
The integral over counter C1.
Maybe I should have
done them curly.
Curly C1 would
have been clearer.
e to the i.
k cubed over 3 plus k u.
That is your integral.
And this is the
phase of integration.
Phase.
Now, in order to find
the asymptotic expansion
for this thing, we'll use a
stationary phase condition.
So the integral is
dominated by those places
where the phase is stationary.
So the 5 prime of k
is k squared plus u.
And we want this
to be equal to 0.
So take, for
example, u positive.
Suppose you want to find the
behavior of the airy function
on the right of the axis.
Well, this says k
squared is equal to u.
So k squared is
equal to minus u.
And that's-- the right hand
side is negative because u is
positive.
And therefore, k-- the
points where this is solved
are k equal plus minus
i square root of u.
So where are those
points in the k plane?
They're here and there.
And those are the places where
you get stationary phase.
So what can you do?
You're supposed to do the
integral over this red line.
C1.
Well, as we argued,
this can be lifted
and we can make the
integral pass through here.
You can now do this
integral over here.
It's the same integral
that you had before.
In this line, we
can say that k is
equal to i square root of
u plus some extra k tilde.
We say here is i square
root of u for u positive.
There is this other
place, but that--
we cannot bring the counter down
here because in this region,
the end points still contribute.
So we cannot shift the counter
down, but we can shift it up.
So we have to do this integral.
So what happens?
You can evaluate that phase
5k under these conditions.
It is a stationary phase point--
this one-- so the
answer is going
to have a part independent
of k tilde, a linear part,
with respect to
k tilde that will
vanish because at this point
the phase is stationary.
And then a quadratic part
with respect to k tilde.
So the phase, 5k, which is
k cubed over 3 plus k u.
When you substitute
this k here, it's
going to give you an answer.
And the answer is going to
be 2 over 3 i u to the 3/2,
plus i square root
of u k squared tilde,
plus k tilde cubed over 3.
That's what you
get from the phase.
You say, well,
that's pretty nice
because now our integral psi
has become the integral d k
tilde over 2 pi.
So you pass from k
to k tilde variable.
e to the minus 2/3.
u to the 3/2.
That is because you
have i times 5k,
so you must multiply by i here.
Then minus square
root of u k squared.
Then plus k cubed.
OK.
Tildes of course.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Um.
Yes.
i k.
This should be like that.
Yes.
OK.
So now what happens?
If u is large enough,
this quantity over here
is going to mean
that this integral is
highly suppressed over k tilde.
It's a Gaussian with
a very narrow peak.
And therefore, we
can ignore this term.
This term is a constant.
So what do we get from here?
We get 1 over 2 pi
from the beginning.
This exponential.
e to the minus 2 over 3.
u to the 3/2.
3/2.
And then from this Gaussian,
we get square root of pi
over square root of
square root of u.
So it's u to the 1/4.
So I think I got it all correct.
And therefore, the function
A i of u goes like--
or it's proportional to
this decaying exponential.
Very fast decaying exponential.
1 over 2.
1 over square root of pi.
1 over u to the 1/4.
e to the minus 2/3.
u to the 3/2.
And this is when u is
greater than 0 and, in fact,
u much greater than
1, positive and large.
So this shows you the
power of this method.
This is a very powerful
result. And this
is what we're going to
need, pretty much, now
in order to do our
asymptotic solutions
and the matching of w k b.
There is an extra term, or an
extra case, you can consider.
What happens to this
integral when u is negative?
When u is negative,
there's two real roots,
and the stationary points
occur on the real line.
The integral is, therefore, a
little more straightforward.
You don't have to even move it.
And we have another
expansion, therefore,
which is A i of u is
actually equal to 1
over the square root of pi.
1 over u, length
of u to the 1/4.
Cosine of 2/3.
Length of u to the
3/2 minus pi over 4.
This is for u less than 0.
So the airy function becomes
an oscillatory function
on the left.
So how does this airy
function really look like?
Well, we have the true airy
function behaves like this.
It's a decaying
exponential for u positive.
And then a decaying oscillatory
function for u negative.
For u negative, it
decays eventually.
The frequency becomes
faster and faster.
And that's your airy
function A i of u.
Here is u.
Your asymptotic
expansions, the ones
that we found up there
for u greater than 1,
match this very nicely.
But eventually they blow up,
so they're a little wrong.
And they actually
match here quite OK.
But here they go and also blow
up because of this factor.
So they both blow up, but
they're both quite wrong
in this area, which you would
expect them to be wrong.
These are the regions where
this two asymptotic expansions
make no sense.
They were calculated
on the hypothesis
that u is much bigger than
1, or much less than 1.
Minus 1.
And therefore,
you get everything
under control except this area.
So now let's do the
real work of w k b.
That was our goal
from the beginning,
so that's what
we'll try to do now.